the New York Post is reporting the White
House privately asked the El Paso mayor
not to declare a state of emergency over
the Border
because it would make Biden look bad
before the midterms
but the mayor
denies that now
did the White House ask you not to
declare a state of emergency
absolutely not you know one of the
things I'm very thankful for the White
House the federal government they've
done a really really good job of working
with us and helping us them but the
mayor lied to Dana and I don't like that
you never disrespect Dana like that
here's what the El Paso Democrat mayor
said a month ago
I had a conversation this morning this
morning or yesterday with uh the chief
of the U.S border Patrol uh Chief Ortiz
and he um he does not support declaring
the state of emergency at this point our
congresswoman has urged for us not to do
that and our County Judge does not
support that at this point we may have
to do that I mean there's going to be a
point where we may have to do that but
at this point and the White House has
asked at this point for us not to do
that
oh
Claudia Rodriguez is on the El Paso city
council Claudia he lied to Dana Perino
and that is a big No-No ah
I know that is crazy especially since we
have the receipts it's literally on in
the internet for the entire world to see
so there's a state of emergency but he
hasn't declared it because he wants to
help Joe keep the Senate
what does that tell you about the
leadership of this country
so I like you mentioned I sit on City
Council in El Paso Texas we're supposed
to be a nonpartisan governmental body
and for me to hear that you know I was
really floored because as long as much
as the mayor wants to say this is not a
political issue
um yeah those comments would probably
say otherwise yeah I'd look under the
table to see what the mayor's taking if
he's going to say I'll do you a favor
Joe what kind of favor are you going to
do me how do you think the migrants are
being treated in New York did you know
that they get buttered popcorn they get
three free culturally appropriate Square
meals a day an Xbox and cribbage do you
guys have free Cribbage down there in El
Paso
no we do not you know we're actually a
very hard-working Community
um and that was the whole issue with
this whole situation is that you know as
you know inflation is terrible and our
community feels overtaxed
um and we were spending general fund
money to fund this entire operation they
weren't okay with it happening at I
guess a very
um minimal level and so I don't know how
the people of New York feel at this
point I think that people of New York
are unhappy with the money that we're
spending on Xboxes for illegal aliens
that's just a hunch I haven't spoken to
any New Yorkers specifically about it
but I feel like I know the people pretty
well here and they're not down with that
Claudia thank you so much good luck down
there anything you want to say to the
mayor after we just caught him in a lie
um I mean mayor you know I know both him
and I are not hostile people I hope that
you know in the future we will
definitely put the people of El Paso
first and really take the politics out
of it all right thank you so much
Claudia Rodriguez we appreciate it
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight